my friend dr nash and total
transformation who is sponsoring this
next segment have been changing lives
all across the valley today we're going
to focus on a few of our clients and
some of their incredible weight loss
stories take a look
dr nash it's always great to have you on
your show and this is one of my favorite
segments where we talk about some of
your clients success stories and we're
going to start with in my opinion it's
one of my favorite success stories your
success story so the main way that i did
it was i stopped putting all the focus
on calories in calories out and focused
on correcting underlying damage so once
i changed the focus on correcting the
metabolic damage everything that i was
doing started to give me the results and
fall into place and that's how i was
able to not only lose the 80 pounds but
then held it eating between two and
three thousand calories a day
yeah and that's what i like to you're
still you're still eating you're not
starving yourself it's just you look
beautiful amazing success stories and
let's start with one of your patients
everyone take a look at becky i lost 42
pounds on dr nash's program i'm seven
pounds away from my goal if i can do
this i can do anything the thing about
becky what i notice is the weight loss
but also there's like there's a glow
about becky yeah everybody says that
when they see her um and it's kind of
funny that you say that because she
found me through another one of my
clients who had amazing success with the
program and at the time that my client
found her she was in tears in a
classroom because she couldn't get this
body to respond the way she wanted to so
the transformation not just with
physical but mental as well was just
astounding with becky
well i think that's why it's a total
transformation it's mental it's physical
it's it's unbelievable everyone let's
take a look at sarah in just three short
months of losing weight i've lost 52
pounds and 35 inches off my waist which
is where i wanted it most 52 pounds but
also the thing that sticks out is that
right 35 inches off of her waist
yeah she's got a lot of amazing points
one she was a busy mom of two children
she was doing a full-time job and doing
a full-time nursing degree at so she
didn't have a lot of time she lost the
weight with me that you see on the video
but then she went on to lose 98 pounds
total so she learned how to do it and
then she was able to do it herself which
is the whole the whole goal that we have
with people and i feel like i say this
all the time but it's true incredible dr
nash absolutely incredible let's take a
look at dave
dr nash was my last shot at losing
weight i went from a 42 to a 32 and lost
66 pounds in six months he says dr nash
was my last shot in my mind he's tried
all these different diets and exercise
and they didn't work he turned to you
and he changed his life yeah and we hear
that a lot in fact women on average will
attempt six or eight weight loss
programs
a year trying to get their weight to
come down and men aren't immune to that
so really it was his last shot at doing
something before he was just gonna give
up and ten inches off his waist guys
know that because a lot of their weight
is always packed in the middle so to go
from a 42 inch to a 32 inch and 66
pounds in six months that's an
incredible dr nash every week you have a
special what do you have this week i do
so of course normally if someone were to
call my office cold and ask to do that
online evaluation it's going to be 97
but when i come on las vegas now i
always want to give a special
opportunity for help for people that
really need it so there are 10 online
evaluation spots right now that are
online that you can book through the
website for 9.97
but they go really super fast
thank you to total transformation for
sponsoring this segment visit drnash.com
eval to take advantage of her special
offer